foreign
oftentimes when you're having a
difficult time making a decision
it's because you're conflating the
decision itself with the implementation
of the decision so it's pretty damn
clear what you need to do what the right
decision is because there's a
constituency here that you're trying to
optimize for so in any organization
there's a human that you are
prioritizing so if it's a company you're
probably prioritizing the customer if
it's an investment firm you're probably
prioritizing your LPS if it's a your own
personal life you need to be
prioritizing you
and then there's implementation there's
someone who when you know that what's
right for the customer and you implement
it someone's going to get hurt maybe
it's that you have someone who's not
performing well if you're making a
decision just for the customer clearly
you would let go of this person but you
know this person is in the middle of
getting a divorce
they are Christmases coming and how will
a person pay for the private school
tuition their kids are in and you don't
want to be the one to impose that pain
and suffering on that person
so you have a really hard time making
this decision but if you separate the
two and think okay customer needs this
person let go this person will be paying
and I will be paying too so I'm going to
get hurt by the implementation then
think of well what does this person
who's going to get hurt by the
implementation what is it that they
really want so the person is going to be
fired
what they really want is Financial
Security they want to find a place where
they are valued they are needed and pays
enough money to cover their life
expenses you what do you really want you
don't want to be the bad guy you want to
not incur impose pain on someone you
actually want to help someone find their
place where they can have what they want
which is Financial Security so what do
you do you then think about how can I
achieve that in the implementation well
you can achieve that by
becoming the person's career agent
you say this is not working here but I
want to help you find the place that's
going to work for you so I know that
you're passionate about a
you right now we're having you do B
and you're not great at it but a you're
great at
let's find a place that needs a and I
will wholeheartedly recommend you for a
in fact I'm not going to just recommend
you I'm going to go out and advocate for
you I'm going to find I'm going to send
out tweets I'm going to send out emails
I'm going to send out texts to people
saying this guy or woman is fantastic at
this can you please consider them
because as an agent one hour of time
spent will equal a hundred hours of time
spent by the candidate themselves once
you're able to separate the two once you
say what's best for the customer clearly
that's what's best how do I minimize the
damage on the person that gets hurt now
you can actually go forward and you can
make a good decision that doesn't
actually hurt people unnecessarily